reno is the county seat of Washoe County
Nevada the city is a population of about
two hundred and eighteen thousand it is
the fourth most populous city in Nevada
it sits in the high desert valley at the
foot of the Sierra Nevada Reno is known
as the biggest little city in the world
as early as the 1850s a few pioneers
settled in the Truckee metals a
relatively fertile valley through which
the Truckee River made its way from Lake
Tahoe to Pyramid Lake gold had been
discovered in the vicinity of Virginia
City 1850 and a modest mining community
developed put the discovery of silver in
1859 led to a nursing of the Comstock
Lode Nevada is still the third largest
gold producer in the world after south
africa and australia in january 1863 the
Central Pacific rota had began laying
tracks Eastern Sacramento California
eventually connecting with the Union
Pacific Railroad at promontory Utah once
a railroad station was established the
time of Reno officially came into being
and may 9th 1868 Reno is home to a
variety of recreational activities in
the summer renal Ogle's can be found
near three major bodies of water lake
tahoe the Truckee River and pyramid lake
skiing snowboarding are among the most
popular winter sports Reno has five
Sister Cities yo Lynette Canada hats or
Israel donostia Spain you don't on EA
Thailand Taichung Taiwan in Shenzhen
China welcome to Reno Nevada well first
you should go on to the wildlife that's
just beyond the city borders or even
inside that you should go to the
mountains go walking in the parks or
whatever because it's really beautiful
also you should go visit a friend
in the University of Nevada you know
because that's very easy being green
means that we should be in touch with
our environment so that we should
recycle we should consider we should try
not to waste things and above all it
means appreciating nature and observing
its quality if I had an unlimited budget
and can travel anywhere in the world I
would travel up to the country of
Georgia which is northeast of Turkey I
would go there because of the seamy
cultured six language and above all it's
pretty Georgia bottle-washer would also
be a fun place to travel to as well
because although it is very mountainous
the islands are quite small and there
are many languages spoken there charge
of the world for a day I would do many
things but the first thing I would do
was would be to UM preserve a lot of
languages to send a bunch of little self
seduction Russian languages because
although it seems like language is a
pretty well documented they actually
aren't because only about two-fifths of
the languages in the world today have
even a Bible translation
so there's a lot of languages that and
more work to be done on them this
decides all languages are directly
linked to the cultures and so if you
don't preserve them you can kind of
destroy the culture as well as we've
been very bold with signal but also I
would um try to get a bunch of people to
get along with each other like I would
try to make Israel and Palestine just
wanted each other and our countries and
all that my main study technique for the
National Geographic Bee is reading
lonely planet or any other brand um
travel books because they tell me a lot
about the history of certain places as
well as telling me about the kazeem
practical practical things that you have
to know when you go to them climate
temperature and also such things like
that they can also tell you about
distinct regions and the things that you
should do when you're in the different
regions so although it may seem a bit
impractical usually they have maps
inside them which also helps as well hey
National Geographic did you know that
the country which has the highest
language densities vanuatu with about 15
square miles to language
you